>> WRITING THE MEAN GIRLS
MUSICAL HAS BEEN A DREAM COME
TRUE.
THE ONLY AWKWARD THING IS PEOPLE
KEEP COMING TO ME SAYING, WHEN
ARE YOU GOING TO BE IN IT?
THE OTHER DAY CECILY STRONG
SAID, GIRL, YOU MUST BE IN IT.
>> WHAT I SAID WAS, GIRL, YOU
MUST BE IN IT MEANING YOU MUST
BE BUSY.
SHE HIGH FIVED ME REALLY HARD
AFTER.
IT WAS CLEAR SHE MISUNDERSTOOD.
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
EXPECTED TINA TO BE IN THE SHOW.
>> SHE'S NOT REALLY LOUD ENOUGH.
SHE HAS A SMALL HEAD.
>> THE THING THAT INSPIRED ME
WAS ONE DAY MY BEST FRIEND AIDY
AND I WERE LISTENING TO THE
HAMILTON SOUND TRACK.
>> TINA KEPT TALKING OVER IT
LIKE LIN WROTE THIS BUT THEY LET
HIM BE IN IT.
>> LEAVE ME OUT OF THIS.
>> DID SHE SAY WE WERE BEST
FRIENDS?
>> TINA IN THE SHOW WILL BE
FETCH.
MEANING IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> WE'RE GOING TO PUT TINA IN
THE SHOW.
>> I AM SO EXCITED FOR ALL OF
US.
AIDY AND CECILY ARE HERE TO
SUPPORT ME BECAUSE IT WAS THEIR
IDEA.
>> NO.
>> I WAS TOLD IT WAS A BABY
SHOWER.
>> SO I'M GOING TO SHADOW YOU
AND SEE WHAT PART IT MIGHT BE
FUN FOR THE AUDIENCE TO SEE ME
DO FOR A WEEK OR SO.
>> ONE MATINEE.
WE AGREED.
>> IT'S NOT JUST THE SOUNDS.
YOU HAVE TO DO THE MOVEMENTS.
>> WHAT IF MY REGINA LOG ROLLS
IN AND HITS A COOL POSE?
>> OKAY.
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY BETTER.
>> GOT IT.
>> WHAT KIND OF VIBRATO SHOULD I
USE?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> SOME PEOPLE DO A STRAIGHT
TONE LIKE -- ♪ BROADWAY ♪
BUT MINE IS WIDER LIKE --
[ SINGING HALTINGLY ]
THIS IS KIND OF A GRETCHEN GOES
TO THE MALL LOOK.
>> YOU LOOK GREAT.
>> MAYBE IS THE WIG BIG?
>> I'M NOT SURE YOU'RE PASSING
AS A TEENAGER.
>> ALSO I CAN'T DANCE IN THESE
SHOES.
MY SHOES CAN ONLY BE BOUGHT IN
PARADE MAGAZINE.
THEY HAVE COPPER IN THEM.
THEY ARE CALLED SUNSET STEPPERS
AND THEY HAVE A POUCH TO HOLD
YOUR PILLS.
♪♪♪
>> AM I DOING IT?
>> THIS COULD BE A FUN USE OF
YOU.
>> IT'S LIKE A FUN EASTER EGG.
THEN I TAKE THE HEAD OFF.
>> EXACTLY.
OR NOT.
♪♪♪
FIVE, SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT.
>> ULTIMATELY I REALIZED THAT
BROADWAY IS HARD AND THE PEOPLE
WHO DO IT ARE SUPER TALENTED.
MAYBE IT'S OKAY IF I CAN'T BE
LIKE LIN-MANUEL AND JAM MYSELF
INTO MY SHOW WHETHER PEOPLE LIKE
IT OR NOT.
>> OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE JUST MADE THE BOOK.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THIS
TINY-HEADED BITCH NAMED TINA.